Recognize and describe people around you with
Seeing AI.
The Seeing AI person channel enables you to
recognize people and to get a description
of them, including an estimate of their age
and also their emotion.
That’s really cool because in that moment
in time, you can find out what someone’s
facial expression was.
When you are taking the photo, the app will
guide you to help you center the face.
And then once you have taken the photo, you
will hear that description .
Let me show you.
Hey Anirudh, can you come here.
Hi Saqib!
I am just demoing this app.
Can I take a photo of you?
Sure!
> One face near top edge 4 feet away.
So I got that guidance near top edge.
So let’s move up a bit and take a photo.
> Take a picture, button
> Processing
> 36 year old male wearing glasses looking
happy
That’s cool. is that accurate?
I should ask.
Yeah and it knows I shaved off my beard.
Yeah, no beard anymore.
Good point.
Very nice.
Thank you very much Anirudh.
Awesome!
That’s really cool!
The other way I find this useful is when I
actually want to take photos of my friends.
So when I take a photo, I can now know that
the face is centered so my photos look a bit
better, which is useful if I’m going to
put it up on Facebook for example.
I also know that the people in my photos are
smiling, which is really nice.
One last thing.
You would have heard that when it’s giving
guidance, it’s just saying the number of
people.
But how cool would it be if it told me who
the people were.
Then I could use it to look for a friend.
You can actually do that by teaching Seeing
AI about your friends.
You simply take photos and type in the names
of your friends.
And the next time, the name will be announced
as well.
> Anirudh near top edge 5 feet away
Microsoft logo appears